ladies and gentlemen please help me in
congratulating the 2020 astros hall of
fame class please welcome him to the
astros hall of fame cesar cedeno ladies
and gentlemen please welcome to the
astros hall of fame
the wizard
roy
oswalt
ladies and gentlemen
billy
wagner
[Applause]
louise garcia he has a 121 strikeouts
232 walks and a very good opponent
batting average at 219.
as he combined that year for 108 and
two-thirds how about this start for luis
garcia only needs eight pitches to get
through the first inning a one two three
start for the astros right-hander bottom
of the first inning michael pineda on
the mound for minnesota four and six
three point eight nine era and 15 starts
the big man pineda will face jose altuve
here to lead things off
as altuve breaks his back but that's
going to find some open grass in center
field jose altuve a lead off base hit
for the astros to start this game kelsen
leads it off for minnesota garcia
delivers
swing get a mess got him on the cutter
away into noah was the first strikeout
victim of luis garcia one away here's
jay cave 3-2 to cave
strike three call at the knees on the
outside corner frozen with a change up
for the second straight strikeout for
garcia two out nobody on for catcher
ryan jeffers
trying to hold up it's a call third
strike jeffers goes down looking luis
garcia strikes out the side kyle tucker
will stand in against michael pineda 3-2
and that's a ground ball pulled into the
shift past the dive of polanco and into
right center for a base hit for tucker
that ends at 0 for 7 in the series
against minnesota here's oledmi's diaz
2-2
and that is ripped through the left side
of base hit tucker will stop at second
and 11 he's diaz is aboard back-to-back
singles for the astros
i'll bring up chaz mccormick mccormick
had
two extra base hits last night a double
in a home run then struck out his final
three at bats
mccormick chops a ground ball simmons
loves it can't make the throw
everybody's safe
rbi for chaz mccormick astros lead one
to nothing would have been a tough play
all the way around as you can tell
simmons even though he got there was
trying to make that throw from his
backside
and it'll end up being an infield hit
which is a good call
because that was really the only
opportunity simmons had was trying to
get that lead runner at second base for
minnesota now it's trevor larnick
leading things off things are a little
different swing and a mess of breaking
ball in the dirt as larnick runs down to
first base after the ball squirted away
from castro barely that's four
strikeouts in a row now for garcia two
outs nobody on for simmons
trying to hold up and he goes around
luis garcia five strikeouts of the last
six batters another one two three inning
rooker into the box now rooker getting a
day off from left field but stays in
that now customary number two spot of
the order
drilled fair into the corner
rooker gets the first hit
he'll round first head to second
seen enough of those breaking balls he
finally found what he could reach yeah
i i was saying he was executing so well
the plan against right-handers and
left-handers and then he hung one to a
three-and-two
hangar to brett rooker and he
drilled it down the left-field line the
tainted batting polanco flew out to
center field his last time up 0-2 got
him strike three got it by polanco
kind of tied him up with that pitch
it's the sixth strikeout for luis and
there's two away oh it gives
yord on alvarez isn't it bad here
if it hits that
it would have been in fair territory
jordan drives one deep to center field
this ball is gone
number 50 of his career jordon alvarez
makes it a two-nothing game on a bolt to
center field
record-setting swing by
jordan alvarez continuing to make his
mark in the astros history books as far
as starting a career
i don't think that was in the air seven
seconds
no it came off the bat at
114.7 miles an hour
there's jordan
fastball coming right back to him and
just nose down barrel to it
extend
and enjoy
[Applause]
cave leads off here right he was just he
wasn't even on anybody's radar at that
point 3-2 strike three call on the
outside corner at the knees and cave
goes down looking seven strikeouts for
luis garcia jeffers was called out on
strikes his first time up
deep to left
and a fair ball
and jeffers trots to second
twins have two doubles both of them
pulled down the line by right-handed
batters top of the fifth here's trevor
larnick he struck out his first time the
kick and the pitch swing and a miss how
about that curve ball on three two
eighth strikeout for luis garcia and
there are two outs
in the top of the fifth two out no one
on for altuve he is singled and fouled
out one for two definitely a sideshow
out there as altuve grounds went through
the middle tough play and nobody's gonna
make it
even if polanco gloves it without duvet
running down the line there is no chance
he is thrown out altuve has his second
hit tonight that is his 35th multi-hit
game of the season here's kyle tucker
that ball roped in the right field
that'll be down for a hit kyle tucker
hits the ball hard to right
he's down two for three tonight only
time he was retired he lined out to
first so he's seen the ball well against
great outing by luis garcia tonight six
innings of shutout baseball only allowed
two hits to not walk anybody he will
turn things over here in the seventh
inning to ryan stanek
swing and a miss stanic at 97 gets a
very good hitter polanco
on strikes to start the seventh and
after this series in houston the twins
will face another team there's a ball
driven to left hit pretty well
and off the wall cave held to a single
amount of time are those innings pitched
in the minor leagues to build towards
something up here
diaz will flip to altuve for the force
out on cave on the ground ball off the
bat of jeffers and that'll do it for the
twins nice inning
for ryan stanek worked around a hit one
man left on base seventh inning stretch
time at minute may park it's two nothing
astros now kyle tucker will bat 1-1
and that is pulled and over the leap of
a rise in the right down to second goes
correa soft single for tucker got it
over the shift
and he is three for four in the led miss
d has an opportunity here for a two out
rbi
ground ball down the line fair ball
correa will score easily tucker's going
to score this ball goes all the way to
the corner oled miss diaz a two rbi
double it's four nothing after
here's miguel cino for three
line drive short hop by correa he's
gonna have to make the throw he does
ball game over four pitcher combined
shutout luis garcia ryan stanley kendall
graven ryan presley
combined on the four-hitter